For eleven years he hosted one of the most
popular art shows on television -- transforming
a blank canvas to a finished painting in a
remarkably short, 30 minutes.
He captivated audiences with his mesmerizing
voice and relaxed demeanor, and of course,
his signature perm.
Nearly twenty-five years after his death,
the painter of “happy little trees” is
immortalized through internet memes, inspirational
quotes, a thriving business in his name, and
reruns of his show The Joy of Painting.
His fame as a pop-culture icon shows no sign
of diminishing yet so little is known about
his life.
Today on Biographics, we piece together the
world of Bob Ross -- beyond the canvas.
Personal Life
Bob Ross was fiercely private and never revealed
details of his personal life.
He gave very few interviews -- claiming no
one bothered to ask him.
Looking for answers is especially difficult
considering no official biography of his life
exists from primary sources.
The one documentary, “Bob Ross: The Happy
Painter” can only be obtained by pledging
money to PBS, or getting a hold of a DVD.
The book, Happy Clouds, Happy Trees: The Bob
Ross Phenomenon, admitted that their “text
is… about an understanding we have of Bob
Ross and his life.
If we had wanted to write an accurate biographical
book on Bob Ross, that goal would be difficult
to accomplish.”
Adding to the elusive Ross; he was said to
have very few friends and they, out of respect,
only ever conducted interviews for the aforementioned
documentary that is not readily or widely
available.
Facts are hard to come by, and nearly impossible
to verify.
Still, some specifics are known and so far,
remain undisputed.
Here’s what we know:
Robert (Bob) Norman Ross was born on October
29, 1942 in Daytona Beach, Florida to Jack,
a builder and carpenter, and Ollie, a waitress.
When Ross was just a year and a half old his
parents divorced and Ross moved to Orlando.
Not much is known of Ross’ childhood in
Orlando -- save for two defining moments.
As a freshman in high school, Ross dropped
out to work as a carpenter alongside his father.
Around the same time, Ross suffered an accident,
losing the tip of his left index finger on
a saw blade.
Ross must have been self-conscious of his
deformed hand for the rest of his life.
On his hit television show The Joy of Painting,
Ross carefully disguised it -- holding his
paint palette so it remained shielded from
view most of the time.
Ross was known to be an animal lover his entire
life.
As a youngster, this may have been passed
on from his mother.
As a teenager, Ross allegedly kept exotic
pets, including armadillos and alligators.
Later on in life, his pet gray squirrel sometimes
made an appearance on his television show.
Ross once said, “If we’re going to have
animals around we all have to be concerned
about them and take care of them.”
Bob Ross married twice during his life and
had three sons.
He married his first wife Lynda Brown early
on in his military career and they divorced
in 1981.
The couple had two sons, Bob Jr. and Steven.
Steven would follow in his father’s footsteps
and become a certified Bob Ross painting instructor.
Ross’ second wife Jane, was a civilian in
Alaska.
They had one son, Morgan, who would also become
an accomplished artist.
Sadly, Jane died from cancer in 1993 and Ross
did not remarry.
Military Career
Long before his time on public television,
Ross was in the military.
At the age of 18 Ross joined the United States
Air Force and within a few years he was uprooted
from his native Florida and sent to an entirely
unfamiliar place -- Fairbanks, Alaska.
Ross spent the next twenty years of his life
in Alaska -- working, raising a family, and
developing a love for painting amid the majestic
mountains, towering pines, and crystal clear
waters.
Examining Ross’ paintings over his lifetime,
one can see without question, the trees, peaks,
valleys and streams are distinctly Alaskan.
Eventually Ross rose through the Air Force
ranks to Master Sergeant after holding positions
as a medical records technician and first
sergeant of the Clinic at Eielson Air Force
Base.
These positions required him to be, in his
own words, “tough” and “mean.”
He was "the guy who makes you scrub the latrine,
the guy who makes you make your bed, the guy
who screams at you for being late to work."
Ross gained a reputation for being hard on
his subordinates who nicknamed him “Bust
’em up Bobby.”
For anyone who has watched Ross on The Joy
of Painting, the image of him as the authoritative,
military figure couldn’t be further from
his television personality.
Apparently, Ross yelled so much during his
military career he never wanted to raise his
voice again after he left the Air Force.
Bob Ross the Painter
Ross’ first brush with painting occurred
at an art class at the Anchorage U.S.O.
club but he clashed with his abstract-loving
instructors.
According to Ross, they failed to teach him
the practical techniques of how to paint.
“They’d tell you what makes a tree, but
they wouldn’t tell you how to paint a tree.”
Fortunately, the experience didn’t turn
him away from painting altogether.
Ross soon found a more suitable painting instructor
on public television.
Ross’ predecessor was an older, German painter
named Bill Alexander.
He hosted a half-hour instructional painting
show, The Magic of Oil Painting, on PBS.
Watching the show, Ross learned how to paint
in the alla prima style (Italian for “first
attempt”), also known in the art world as
“wet-on-wet.”
Ross perfected the technique -- which allowed
him to complete a finished work in a single
session.
Unlike other painting methods, when an artist
uses alla prima, he or she can add wet paint
in layers without waiting for the paint to
fully dry.
Alexander falsely claimed to have invented
the style but it actually dates back to the
fifteenth century in Flanders (modern-day
Belgium).
Alla Prima was popular with many famous artists
throughout history but enjoyed great fanfare
among the Impressionist painters in the nineteenth
century.
Notably, it was a favorite technique of artists
Claude Monet and John Singer Sargent.
After further honing his skills, Ross decided
to supplement his Air Force pay by selling
landscapes painted on the inside of gold prospecting
pans to tourists.
It was a lucrative endeavor and when his earnings
from paintings surpassed his military salary,
he resigned to become a full-time artist.
The Joy of Painting
Upon leaving the Air Force, Ross returned
to Florida and sought out Bill Alexander to
perfect his painting skills.
By that time, Alexander taught art classes
in his spare time and happily took the eager
Ross under his wing.
Alexander didn’t realize Ross would later
take everything he knew from these lessons,
make his own show, and rise to the level of
superstardom -- which eventually led to their
falling out.
During their early meeting, Alexander was
impressed with Ross and he hired him as a
traveling tutor for the Alexander Magic Art
Supplies Company.
At the same time, nine hundred miles away
from Alexander’s studio in Clearwater, Florida,
a woman named Annette Kowalski was experiencing
a debilitating depression after losing her
oldest son in a traffic accident.
Unable to get up, she laid in bed all day
watching television episodes of The Magic
of Oil Painting.
Desperate and hoping to cheer his wife up,
Walter Kowalski signed Annette up for a five-day
painting class with Alexander...or so she
thought.
Before Annette’s arrival, Alexander had
passed on his classes to an unknown instructor
known simply as Bob.
Annette was incredibly disappointed when she
heard Alexander was not longer instructing,
but Walter insisted she go anyway saying,
“Get in the Car.
We’re going.”
Over the course of the five day painting class
whatever misgivings Annette first had about
Ross completely disappeared.
In fact, taking that class, she recognized
there was something very special about him.
Looking back years later Annette said, "I
was so mesmerized by Bob.
"Somehow, he lifted me up out of that depression….I
just think that Bob knew how to woo people.”
Wooing people was Ross’ calling card.
Annette was on to something and saw in Ross
an opportunity to “put it in a bottle and
sell it.”
She believed Ross was capable of making a
fortune and she wanted in.
After the class, Annette and her husband took
Ross out to dinner and brokered a business
deal.
From that point on, Annette became Ross’
manager -- sinking her entire life savings
into the partnership.
Ross and his wife ponied up a similar amount
of capital.
As manager, Annette focused on taking out
ads in the local papers and setting up painting
seminars at various malls.
She even established a toll-free telephone
hotline, 1-800-BOB-ROSS.
But for people to really connect and experience
the allure of Bob Ross, she needed to get
him in front of as many people as possible.
They filmed a commercial, and possibly a pilot
television show to sell to PBS executives.
Eventually, all the hard work and hustle paid
off and Ross landed his own show on the network,
The Joy of Painting.
The first episode aired on January 11, 1983.
The Joy of Painting enjoyed an eleven year
run on PBS from 1983 to 1994, filming 403
episodes in total.
During the 30 minutes of airtime for each
show, Ross stood in a dark room with a blank
canvas and painted an imaginary landscape
scene.
There were two cameras for the program, shot
in real-time -- a medium shot of Ross and
his canvas, and a close-up shot of the canvas
or palette.
Ross faithfully instructed oil painting to
viewers at home in the alla prima style -- the
same technique he previously learned from
Bill Alexander.
With little more than smudges, blotches, and
scrapes from his palette knife, Ross created
masterpieces.
To keep the lessons inexpensive for people,
the tools and color selection was limited.
Though he surely had the technique down, Ross’
real
draw for audiences was his calming presence,
slower-paced speech, warm voice, and words
of encouragement sprinkled in while instructing.
In this way, Ross is often compared to Fred
Rogers, the iconic children’s show host
of Mister Rogers Neighborhood.
On The Joy of Painting, there was no pressure
from Ross.
He believed everyone could “paint almighty
pictures” and “there are no mistakes,
only happy accidents.”
The Joy of Painting proved to be an immediate
success for the PBS network.
For some viewers, it was a reprieve from the
harsher realities of life, or the doldrums
of other television programs.
When asked about his consoling approach, Ross
said, "I got a letter from somebody here a
while back, and they said, 'Bob, everything
in your world seems to be happy.'
That's for sure.
That's why I paint.
It's because I can create the kind of world
that I want, and I can make this world as
happy as I want it.
Shoot, if you want bad stuff, watch the news.”
The Joy of Painting was like a personal art
lesson, described by his manager Annette as
“liquid tranquilizer.”
Yet amazingly, only about 10 percent of viewers
painted along with Ross.
The other 90 percent tuned in to simply watch
him.
Ross worked quickly to create his masterpieces
-- swirling the paint around, dabbing it here
and there -- and grabbing for his two-inch
brush every now and then saying, “Now, let’s
get crazy.”
He made the whole process of painting look
completely effortless.
The truth is, Ross was meticulous and his
manager Annette referred to him as a “tyrant.”
Ross was not mean or nasty according to Annette
but he was every bit a businessman as he was
a painter.
He wanted everything on the show to be perfect
and done his way.
Before filming each episode, Ross would lay
awake at night planning and rehearsing exactly
what he would say.
No one watching would ever know -- Ross always
appeared to be calm and free form on camera.
His planning extended to more than the words
he said.
For each episode of The Joy of Painting, Ross
didn’t complete just one painting.
He always finished three.
Ross painted one while filming (the one everyone
saw), another was done before and sat just
off-camera for Ross to use as reference, and
the final painting, a more detailed work,
was completed after the show and was photographed
for use in Ross’ instruction books.
Ross was never actually paid for appearing
in any of The Joys of Painting shows on PBS.
Instead, he used it to promote his teaching
business -- which worked spectacularly to
expand interest after the first episode.
The business, Bob Ross Inc., eventually grew
to include paint supplies branded by Bob Ross
and the company and Ross raked in millions
of dollars.
To further bring his brand into the spotlight,
Ross occasionally appeared on talk shows and
appeared in promotional gigs; some of these
included MTV, The Joan Rivers Show, Phil Donahue,
and as a guest at a Hank Snow country music
concert at the Grand Ole Opry.
The final The Joy of Painting show aired on
May 17, 1994 after Ross was diagnosed with
cancer.
Ross’ son Steven, who made regular appearances
on the show, appeared with his father on the
set.
Bob Ross the Brand
Most of Ross’ image was intentionally created
-- except for his trademark afro.
Believe it or not, his hair wasn’t even
naturally curly -- it was straight.
Before he officially had ‘made it,’ Ross
ditched his short, military crew cuts for
a longer style and perm as a way to save money.
Once his perm was a hallmark of the Bob Ross
brand, he couldn’t bring himself to change
it even though he grew to dislike it.
Later, after Ross got sick from Lymphoma cancer
and lost all his hair to chemotherapy treatments,
he wore a wig on his show to keep up his appearance.
Ross’ outfits were another carefully crafted
element of his “look.”
On The Joy of Painting Ross wore casual blue
jeans with a button-up shirt...the top buttons
were left undone to reveal a bit of chest
hair.
This timeless look was intended to appear
“current” when PBS aired reruns of shows
later on.
A private man, Ross and his manager Annette
told a backstory of his life that was light
on biographical details.
The story emphasized modest beginnings, a
love of nature and animals, and philosophy
that every person matters.
His caring personality extended to his viewers,
students, and injured animals that he took
in and cared for.
The narrative continues to be pushed today
by the business, Bob Ross, Inc.
Illness & Death
In 1994, Ross was dealt a devastating blow
with his diagnosis of Lymphoma, a rare type
of cancer.
Lymphoma is in a group of blood cancers -- it
attacks the lymphatic system.
The lymph nodes and glands, along with a network
of vessels, are an important part of the body’s
circulatory functions that aid in a person’s
immune system.
Many people with Lymphoma never have or display
symptoms, and it isn’t unknown how much
Ross suffered from his disease.
Ross kept his cancer diagnosis out of the
public eye, only telling his closest friends
and relatives.
He reportedly painted right up until the end,
and died in 1995 at the age of 52.
At his grave at Woodlawn Memorial Park in
Gotha, Florida, a simple stone marker reads:
“Bob Ross, Television Artist.”
Bob Ross’ Legacy
Bob Ross was a prolific artist, purportedly
completing 30,000 paintings during his lifetime.
With so many Ross paintings out in the world,
it would seem relatively easy to find one
and buy it to hang above the living room couch.
Not true -- anyone wanting to purchase one
today would be hard-pressed to find an original.
The reason for this being, there are so many
copycat and fraudulent versions that have
flooded the marketplace.
And, virtually all of Ross’ paintings made
on The Joy of Painting he donated to PBS fundraisers
to raise money for other public broadcasting
programs.
Today the company, Bob Ross Inc. is going
strong and is still managed by Annette and
Walter Kowalski.
The company sells a variety of paints, brushes,
art kits, easels, canvases, instructional
DVDs and books.
On their website one can find and order Bob
Ross branded apparel -- including socks, T-shirts,
and baby bibs.
There are an array of accessories and wacky
gifts, including coffee mugs, glasses -- even
a certified Bob Ross Chia Pet.
Beyond the official merchandise, one can find
just about anything with the Bob Ross image
-- a quick Google search returns a prayer
candle named for ‘Saint Bob Ross.’
The company Bob Ross, Inc. still trains and
certifies painting instructors who desire
to work, teach, and promote themselves in
the spirit of the artist.
Most recently, Netflix has licensed shows,
adding Ross’ series, Beauty Is Everywhere
and The Joy of Painting to its lineup.
In pop-culture, references to Bob Ross and
his aphorisms are everywhere.
His likeness and inspirational quotes live
on through internet memes.
Google celebrated Ross for what would have
been his seventieth birthday in 2012 with
an Google Doodle, an image of Ross painting
the letter “g” with a landscape in the
background.
He has been mentioned in many popular television
shows such as Family Guy and The Boondocks;
Target stores carry a Bob Ross board game,
Bob Ross: The Art of Chill.
If all this wasn’t enough, the LEGO company
has created a Bob Ross LEGO figure, complete
with a paintbrush and palette.
His icon status shows absolutely no signs
of diminishing.
It seems Ross’ legacy will never die -- and
his fans will continue to honor and celebrate
the man for years to come.
Ross once said, “Didn’t you know you had
that much power?
You can move mountains.
You can do anything.”
He showed us he could create a better place
-- a world filled with “happy little trees”
that was free of judgement -- where everyone
was an artist and every landscape was full
of majestic wonder.